In this problem, we have to determine that if we have some code that does some stuff,
and we have a list, and we compute some solution,
that if I insert this call to the function "proc" 1, 2, 3, or 4 as we'll go through them
that this code behaves exactly the same no matter what else it does. So let's get to it.
In this first procedure, there's only one line.
We set the first value of p to equal its second value.
This is going to change the elements in p.
I mean, if we had in a list [1, 2] executing proc1 would then change it to [1, 2].
Obviously, that can very well effect how this could execute, so this isn't right.
This one can be a little tricky, so let's work through it.
We know that p is a pointer to a list--let's say it's 1, 2, and 3.
Now we're reassigning what p points to to the original value of p, which is this,
concatenated with the list 1.
This is going to create a new list, because that's what the plus operator does with lists.
We want to create a new list.
Now p points to this. We don't do anything with p.
But most importantly the original list has been left unchanged.
The end result is that this is good.
We can go through this problem like we did the previous one.
We start with a variable p that points to a list.
We then create a new variable "q," which points to the same thing as p.
On p we append 3, and then on q, which is the same list, we pop 3.
The end result is the same list we had before.
Here we create a new list called "q," which is an empty list. There's nothing there.
While p is not empty, we append onto q what we pop from p.
If we remember, the pop is going to take the last entry in p and return it.
It's going to pop off 32, and then we're going to append that on the q.
This is going to continue until we have the reverse of the previous list here and p is empty,
which I'll just symbolize with that.
Then we're going to reverse the process here.
If I undo what I just did, the end result is we have the original list, and we have the empty list.
Although, this doesn't matter.
The main point is that we still have our original list.
This one is good.